today's lecture the topic of today's
lecture will be
um rook and games by akiva rubenstein
um to be honest i was hesitating
how to how to spell his name correctly
in english
because in polish where i'm in poland uh
where i'm from in polish language we say
always rubinstein
but i know that you know i think in here
in us
it says it's it should be spelled
rubinstein or rubinstein
or something like this so uh i want to
use one form uh
so probably i'll stick with the one that
i learned you know as a case and how i
speak in polish
robinstein but uh
sorry for a confusion because i mean
it's more natural for me to speak
rubinstein
so that's why basically that's the only
reason why you would choose this
this way but you know it's the same
player
same great player who
rubin stein so rominstein
okay anyway
[Music]
we know who are we talking about he's
the same great player
uh akibori rubinstein rubinstein same
thing
polish grandmaster from early 19th
century
uh 20th century i'm sorry
and and he was one of the pioneers of
modern basically endgame play
[Music]
and
okay so you know what instead of rubbish
i'm just going to be talking akiba
because
uh akiba it will not be any confusion
with the name akipa
so i will maybe use this then
okay let's get started so i'm gonna
prepare several games on rook and games
[Music]
um in in which uh
akiba winston uh basically uh performed
uh you know one i mean like one of his
finest let's say rook and games
and uh in those games he presented uh
kind of like pioneer ideas i think at
the time
and there's a lot to learn from because
modern let's say end game theory and
very often supported by engine and
analysis uh supports his choices
sometimes he doesn't of course you know
it's just evolved as a game but
nonetheless uh his contribution to the
chess and game
uh or like just any game theory or just
endgame let's say
you know knowledge and so on uh was
immense
and even though maybe at some point uh
you know he at some position would have
played better according to engines of
course
you know everyone makes mistakes right
but his uh let's say overall general
level of playing how he played rook and
games is
was pretty much for the times
astonishing and still uh
i think is um you know
um very very um
impressive even nowadays after checking
with engines and so on
and um so let's get started so the first
game i want to talk about is
one of the let's say simplest rook and
games let's start with let's say simpler
ones then we're going to
go to more complex ones uh
i become akiba or winston versus
emmanuel alaska
so um
wait uh
yeah so basically uh after you know the
inc again very interesting middle game
we got to
some position like this uh you know
akiba mishna
was winning here already earlier but he
transposed to
he transferred to the rook end game uh
feeling that his skills are you know
i mean sufficient to win this and this
is the first position i want to talk
about
because in this position there will
right now
akipa had choice whether to play rook f1
or play king f2
and i think it is very instructive
especially for the times
that he played with king f2 the idea of
king f2
is basically yes he gives away the f2
the b2 pawn by
you know rudy looking at three rook
takes b2 but he gets to play rook a5 and
he still retains extra pawn
and he keeps his rook active which is
the most important
and forces black group to be extremely
passive on b7
could be sentenced for otherwise spawn 7
was false so this was a very important
you know idea here for uh that akhibar
misha demonstrated
because what is the problem with move
rook f1 similarly rook f1 is very
natural move which as you know uh we are
checked we don't want to lose the pawn
we just play rook burger file and
you know we should win and yes white
should win this game anywhere even after
this move
but this is will be not uh uh this
wouldn't this wouldn't be
such a great move from technical point
of view
right after rook d2 it's black group
that's very active even though
white retains two extra pawns uh for now
uh let's say after ruby one they you
know
basically uh with such passive rook
uh white will have very hard time i
think of winning it
and yes two extra pounds should be
sufficient still but
it wouldn't be you know the most
technical way of playing it
and uh here uh lagas alaska would have
had definitely some chances to
save it and um okay rookie two wouldn't
still work yet because of this
it would transfer to rook pawn and game
and white wins obviously
however uh there could be possibility to
play with a5 a4 maybe bring the king a
little bit forward
um instead let's say a5 looks
interesting you know to
you know maybe gain some see some space
maybe king e6 and
or maybe king d6 all moves are possible
also the king is active rook is active
white pieces are not active so uh that's
why it's very important to play this
inspiration not to look f1 but king f2
to activate the king give up give the
one of the extra pawns
and now luke a5 activate the rook and
since now uh his i mean akiba's
technique was brilliant
there will be after b7 rook a6 very nice
move uh
cutting the king on the sixth range just
in case uh
right now uh the basically those pawns
supported by the king are simply going
forward there is no way
uh pretty much to uh to stop them and
uh black can be black is forced to
defense different passively with the
rook only on the seventh rank
and uh there is no way
to activate this rook even because at
the a7 pawn falls and with its entire
position
so let's see how the game concluded king
of eight e4 slowly pushing both pawns
forward screen key rook seven
h4 king f7 just g4 everything goes
smooth
very smoothly forward a king f4 king e7
h5 h6 uh fighting king f5
king f7 and e5 there is no way of
stopping that there is pretty much no
way
black would have tried to put pawn on g6
but then even after trade of those pawns
would it wouldn't matter
at all and uh right now here will be
seven
rook d6 uh one let's say a good way so
to play this i i the fret is of course
right now even rook d7
to let's say if black plays move like
this already rook d7 would win the game
because after this disc
is uh we transfer the pawn and game and
king
six simply wins the puzzle wins here
over spawns on the queen's
king side so that's why uh you know uh
king seven was played simply tell
me tested him once and now uh
you know okay maybe it was time trouble
i don't know it was more than 38
possible time trouble it doesn't really
matter but position is anyway winning
rook c6 here finally move a3 and here
i think because they reached time
control white simply black simply
resigned
because there is simply nothing to
to do here with black basically uh if
the king
moves from f7 the king goes forward uh
rook cannot move leave the seventh rank
because then uh
rook c7 follows and if a5 then rook a6
and then
uh you know for instance after a5 or k6
uh pawn is attacked if group b5 will go
through a7
for instance and the game is also so
decided
so uh yeah so very nice and tired
and game play by akiba and um
you know this idea uh also once again of
giving away the the two extra one deck
two one extra pawns that he had
to activate his pieces and king and rook
just look at the final picture in this
position uh for this position in
this position king is extremely active
rook is extremely active right
it's something that would never have
occurred if the white play here
f1 root 2 p1 look at those pieces they
are extremely passive
so this was a very nice here played by
rugenstein all right so this was the
first game i want to talk about
next idea next game i wanted to talk
about
i prepare several of them i know which
one to start with to be honest
let's start with the classic let's start
with the classic game yanovsky versus
rubinstein and
do you guys know this game uh i'll maybe
put the position
before actually we got the rook end game
oh sorry my screen
before we go before we get to the rook
end game
however
okay do you guys know this game the
disposition
okay yeah uh
so this is okay some of you know the
position
some don't uh anyway this is kind of
famous game
uh one of the things famous game most
famous games to be honest by
rubinstein uh basically uh the
uh the last movie was queen takes e4 so
the point is that in this position um
black is uh somewhat
better i would say not not not too much
because you know the
position is pretty much balanced
equal material the only advantage
that white sorry black has is you know
uh put pressure on the f5 actually we
can flip the board to be honest
uh flipping the board makes sense
because we are interested from black's
perspective
uh black you know has some pressure on
the f-file
pawnee free is potentially a weakness
but black is on but on the other hand
white is very solid isn't there is no
kind of clear way to
uh to you know to make make progress
and here uh robuston came up with a very
interesting
maneuver he played with queen d8 can you
guy can you guys
tell me in chat what is the idea of 28
correct queen d8 at the queen b8 queen
a7
correct that's the idea um queen g5
is also possible but this is
uh or queen of six also is possible
totally correct but
idea of rubinstein here was something
totally different
the queen the idea of queen b8 queen a7
sorry look we say we see queen bj queen
a7 and bring this queen to this diagonal
and basically the queen joins the game
c5 for instance it goes from this this
way
so this is the point queen d8 in the
rainfall queen g4 stopping queen g5 i
guess
uh janoski was thinking queen g5 was
you know rubbish idea uh but he goes the
other way around
queen b8 king g2 q87
very nice idea and uh finally
uh you know queen comes to before queen
gets activated look at first it was
queen on d7
he wasn't doing much right now with this
maneuver queen
puts a lot of pressure on the spawn on
the queen side potentially maybe the
idea is to play a5 a4
to put some pressure here or maybe play
b5 at some point as well
depends on what white does of course
um also we can just but probably a5 a4
will be my guess
and so i i know it's a little mostly
about rook end games but the
queens will be trying at some point and
i could not help myself i just had to
show this idea of queen gay queen b8
because
it's classic uh all right so uh rook e2
right now rook f6
uh queen d3
uh king g8 a regular move also if i was
possible to start with
queen c3 a5 uh so finally queens uh
why decide to trade the queens and which
makes perfect sense
takes takes c3 takes takes and
you know we got to this rook end game so
uh what
what should black do in this position
so
okay so this is just in g5 uh there is
suggestion of
rook a8 and uh
yeah interrogate again okay again b6
stop c5
uh okay so uh freestyle is free ideas
ideas to play g5
and idea is to play b6 i used to play
movie k8
so let me start with g5
g5 is incorrect in my opinion uh
g5 you are not creating any series any
serious first on the queenside by
playing uh
kingside by playing with g5 instead you
have to
basically play uh i mean after rg5 i'm
going to play first in rook a2
and i'm gonna control the eight file and
i'm gonna uh play uh
you know uh against this pawn is b7
you know i'm gonna put a lot of pressure
here on on your queen side
and the only open file while boot sees
uh control of
so that's why g5 is a mistake so is b6
but idea of b6 i like a little bit more
because uh b6 i
idea is to start both c5 and this is
this is a general in general is a good
idea
and but but again after b6 i'll play
again rook a2 and
i would control the open file therefore
in this position
uh the best move is to play rook a8 as
many as movies suggested
however rook after rook a8
um after rook a8
uh oh no g5 then g4 okay hold on
uh what are you doing just i'll take i
just you're just
i'm just taking it and you're not
getting anywhere with that
uh so uh rook a8 has to be played and
the the point is
uh the point is of rook a8 uh are you i
look at it and then b6
stop okay correct but okay so uh right
now after rookie let's flip the board
and see what wood you play with white
what is that okay black is slightly
better right it's clearly still
black all the time is everywhere
slightly better at least maybe
maybe not kind of from maybe engines
don't show it or something
but let's say from human perspective
black is slightly better it's difficult
to play this person
white because black white is forced to
be constantly on the defensive side
and you know it's difficult to
to play at least this is my feeling
uh c5 yes c5 is the best move
and basically idea of c5 is to simplify
the position open the c5 activate those
rooks
correct c5 is the best move and uh
that's why
uh you know this was the best defense
key for
this flip again there was the best
defense for why to play music
open c file and the attack
may play rook c7 and so on however in
this position
uh yanovsky doesn't feel any danger
because seemingly there is no any danger
yet
like there is nothing attacked there is
no
even one single fret and uh you know
there is simply it may seem like there
is no rush to
you know play anything uh concrete and
this totally
and also invite point there is no need
to play c5 just yet
but the thing is or like you know to
force equality for some equality
equalizing let's say
ideas in order to you know get the game
uh you know more
even uh because uh seemingly there is no
need right because
thing things are looking still quite
decent for white there is no
like in rush to do it it may seem so in
the game follow king h3
and uh of course right now we play move
b6 as
uh somebody suggested uh idea is to put
obviously b6
to play move uh to stop c5 pretty much
stopping c5
and if this specifier stopped right now
black controls the open file
open a file and we'll try to invade with
rook a1 and so on
bone on f3 also is a weakness bomb
before
wasp on the queen side could become
potentially we can
weaken a little bit as well but mostly
uh you know we try to at first
advance the rook and slowly gradually
improve our position
serve the rule to not hari king g4
so this is a little bit a weird maneuver
by uh yanovsky here
but it's still quite okay it's still
quite okay to play like that
rook a1 obviously activate the rook and
right now again uh in this position um
okay i'm not i was gonna ask you would
you play but i will explain a few things
basically in this position again white
had to somehow
realize that um
what is worse white is wars at least
maybe not on
let's say uh from huma but it's a point
of view only
but it's still worse it's uh you know
black is black has initiative black is
trying to push here
for a win what is on the defensive side
that's why i have to remove rook a1
white was supposed to play move f4 and
uh you know
it's not better no better timing for
this move than now
uh simply idea of a four is to first of
all simplify the position a little bit
uh and the second thing is to
simply go for uh i mean go for
activation of this e2 roof maybe idea of
re7 in the future
maybe basically we need to somehow avoid
activate those ropes open files for
those works because if you look at
black rooks right now they're extremely
active pawn free could be a target
regular one's also very active but white
rooks are not doing anything they're
just kind of stuck there and they're not
great doing anything that's why f4 at
least opens the e file
for this rook and uh you know
maybe if the trades follow uh maybe this
one comes to g
free maybe this one comes back to e7
there is some counter play involved in
those rooks
of course black still can push a little
bit but objectively let's have to look
f1 uh rook e4 uh the game should
somehow end with a draw uh with corrupt
with best defense which of course
is not granted that will happen during
the game
but still you know
white black is still a little bit per
pawn structure so it gives some at least
practical chances
in the game however ayanovsky penis
position played move rook
b2 and idea of rook b2 is also
understandable but it's unfortunately
for white here
wrong idea of a rook b2 is played b4 and
c5
and uh because immediately before we
have been met by probably move like
group b1 and
for attacking this ball and if b5 again
rook a1 and those pawns are right now uh
stuck there they don't go anywhere
possible is again a potentially a
weakness
so uh this wouldn't lead anywhere uh
therefore uh
he tries to play move rook b2 to play
support before and then play c5
but this unfortunately for him doesn't
work right now uh
just king h7 there is no need to rush
strings b4
uh idea is to play move c5 uh but it
simply again doesn't work just king g6
suddenly this king on g4
is in some sort of maybe not maybe not
really
not maybe not just yet but it is getting
into some mating net
uh in some lines uh because you know it
comes into h5 check pawn on the f3 then
it's also
sort of loose the skin doesn't really
belong on g4 that's why this idea of
king bringing bringing the skin to g4
without following you up with f4
was bad uh you know if you if you're
playing a trick into for player four
if not just keep your king on g2
so in this position after c5
uh right now this pawn d5 becomes
extremely weak and perhaps
uh what yanovski measured after rook d1
uh
c takes d6 c takes d6
um looks if rookies is there is b5 and
pawn d5 is any way lost and we cannot
after this which simply protects pawn b5
and black weighs upon and
has winning position also and if b5 at
first
then after rook takes d5 x6 seemingly
this pawn bc is lost
uh but unfortunately there is rook d4
king h3 and d5
and the spawn uh one b6 is guarded by
rugen from f6
and black simply wins the game again so
uh
c5 is not possible therefore after
moving king g6
position is already very shaky probably
is already lost
so let's see but let's see how uh
rubenstein converted it
because it's still similarly not easy
rook b3
the supporting spawn f3 makes perfect
sense
but right now rook f5 suddenly this king
is getting
into more and more trouble right now
rook c2 just sort of staying in place uh
you look h1 activating the rook again
right now that is ruby g5 rogue h5
finally uh you know i mean the point of
this play right now by black is
gradually put more pressure on the
opponent uh
you know h4 right now is impossible
because we've made h5
it's difficult it's getting more and
more difficult to make moves here for
for white and that's the uh point
because even though if position is
objectively you know close to let's say
equal or
or you know maybe okay maybe heroes very
back is
who has a huge advantage right but in
many positions where even they're
supposedly equal if we keep on playing
if we could keep making you know some
progress
and putting some more uh pressure on our
opponent
uh there is a proof possibility that at
some point this tension will be pretty
much
uh uh not not possible to uh
withstand and that's the basically
the the point of you know sort of like
uh
slowly gradually you know uh putting
more pressure on our opponents
and in this end game rubinstein
did perfectly so in the game for the f4
and this was already kind of like
i mean a little bit too late finally f4
uh was played but
this little should have been played long
long time ago right now black simply
wins
other moves were not saving the the day
either for instance after move c5
also you know following this plan uh
you know we've opened for open open the
queen side
and activate those rooks somehow this
simply fails to
do bishop g5 king h3 number simply h5
and unfortunately after a king ju2 is
just made
and if king g4 rook takes h2
and again there is also again threatened
uh
threatened mate in one with h5 so after
takes takes let's say f4
uh again we just back and play this king
of three and then king f5
and the end game is simply one for uh
for black there is no need to take on
ec5
uh because then we will spawn on e5
instead we just implement
king f5 ourselves uh cdcd
then if cbcb uh this is just just
just lost for white so uh
really nice uh here play by uh
rubinstein in the gravel b f4 but this
is also
not sufficient to hold it take stakes
h5 basically right now y has too many
weaknesses and they
are sort of just falling rook king g3 g1
king f2 rogue g4 pawn for just false
ruger 3 takes takes and
yeah there was also one okay maybe few
moments when whenever uh you know group
is
imprisoned nice technique ruger free
king d4
and right now very nice move by
rubinstein move root b3
basically provoking this move b5 trying
to
get this uh pawn to
uh you know light square and that that
therefore the c5 pawn breakthrough will
not be possible
uh still rouge two the game went on a
few more moves king h6 to get out of
checks and finally move b5
if rook a2 there will be very nice move
right now by black
and not group b4 because before we met
by king c3
b1 and rook a7 with some counter play so
the caution needs to be you know till
the end pretty much
because right now uh what can black do
let me ask you
guys black to play in this position no
rook takes before but what
b5 just b5 correct
b5 is the move uh b5 is the move
okay b5 is the move
correct and you basically save the five
king rotates before
and the point is that uh when we switch
the move order
and so this this simply works b5
b5 uh takes who takes before and after
king goes anywhere we just take it upon
b5 and we win
uh someone asked can you take the pawn
uh if you take the pawn that's why
that's what i just said after you before
king c3 and the rook has to go here and
then
rook a7 with counter play
yeah we want to basically do win this
pre-four point which correct
so in the game for b5 uh rookie two was
not sufficient
uh but after rook b5 very nice move by
right now
by uh rubbish rook f3 basically
rook comes back to the f file with idea
of carrying the king on the f file
this white king on f5 and bring this
group to f7
in any time uh one on seven will be
attacked when if someone will guard it
and then pawns hmg will simply go
by themselves with the support of the
king and
and black black wins uh so in a way for
king e4
uh rook f6 um now we need to call rogue
seven just yet look for this is fine
rook a2 but now g5 ideas also to play
rook f4
and this is what he starts with we'll
get four check now rule f7 just as i
said and those pawns on the king side
simply move forward there is a way of
stopping them
and again for simply c5 uh sort of last
hope but this is not sufficient takes d6
and now very nice move again d7
and the game is just over so the rest is
pretty much very nice technique but uh
already uh not too difficult technique
rook d4
king f5 h4 and
looks here if you if the if the rooks is
safe simply king h5 from bbc's rook f4
and
f2 wins the game as well
if rook c8 look f4 c4 king
yeah king g6 check finally using h5
and simply c3 and yeah this basically
is just lost because we've got three and
we capture h3 pawn
and we have too many pawns that black
simply
sorry white can't simply stop white uh
white is widely resigned here uh so it
was a very nice end game
here by aki barbinstein and one of the
very important games let's say for just
history sort of i think like in terms of
you know the quality
instead of in terms of you know the
technique and so on
uh all right so let's look at the next
game that i
prepared and the next game let's switch
which let's do it
maybe against
alexander alejand it's also pretty
famous game
we are a little interested about the
opening obviously we're mostly
interested but
end games so let's begin our discussion
in this moment so after the opening
uh yeah it was a nice grind yeah
so here another end game by akiba
rubinstein
versus alexander alekhine former world
champion
and let's see how akiba managed to
outplay uh world champion
uh i don't know when exactly this game
was played i don't remember
uh i don't know if at the time alexander
was world champion or like contender or
what
because i don't remember what when was
this game played
however uh alekheim was still alejand
right
so um yes what is much better correct
but you know it requires still some
technique to uh
to to win this you know because so far
everything is well defended
everything is well defended pawns on a7
is a weakness i agree
pawn defies the weakness as well how are
they above the well defended by rogue
only seven and uh
any time the other was ready to just
join
so uh right now white played move
rook ac one rook fd8 and
right now uh yeah what would you play in
this position
what would you play in this position
yes two weaknesses but they're all well
guarded
okay rook c7 suggestion any other
[Music]
suggestions
okay so here's my question why would you
play rook c7
uh why would you want to trade those
rooks
get king up um
okay so here is what i think okay i got
your suggestions
let me tell you what i think in this
position probably there are many moves
which they know offering a huge
advantage to white
but i in my opinion if i look at this
position
i ask myself which piece needs to be
improved the most
and when i look at when i answer this
question the answer is very clear
king on g1 just needs to be brought to
the game and
you know we will and then and then i see
what next
bring the king to the game first then
see what next that's why here
the best move is simply move king f1
this is exactly what uh
rubinstein did
rook c7 is possible i'm not saying it's
not possible but why would you trade
rooks
like okay i i'm not gonna of course
capture never gonna capture
and voluntarily lose the game i'll just
play play queen
sick king e6 or something and save your
tag i take back and
okay like you're still not doing
anything with your king
if you look at this position uh you know
essentially by trading those rooks
okay this is still great it's still
great the rules were traded later in the
game
uh you know it's also you know you know
possible
but it is not a good good moment to do
it like at first bring your king then
see what's gonna happen next
so that's why here after you know king
of one
uh i mean the king of one is to be
played okay
at first there's there is no need to
rush the recession with rook traits and
so on rook d6
and now uh ruby strain played very
interactive move he didn't trade rooks
he and this is very instructive my
opinion
because his rooks are stronger than his
opponent's rooks
they're on the open file they had he
chooses to trade or not to trade
and you know those rooks can go from the
queen side uh
like with rook a31 or maybe you can go
from the king side with rook h1 idea and
so on
and also they can stay on the c file uh
you know and make good use of it as well
so basically he combines various ideas
in
this position so uh rook d7 back because
already
rook a3 rook a1 was a big threat so rook
d7 and are simply king d3
no need to rush with rook c6 group 7 or
anything like that first bring it to the
free then see what's going to happen
next
so king d3 rook a8 and uh right now
again back
back to rook c6 rook d6 alekhine wanted
to trade
try to the pair of rooks but
okay and uh yeah in this position i
think rubinstein made a mistake actually
so uh let's see what what
what was wrong he played the move
uh okay maybe it was still still a
mistake but
it was maybe some sort of inaccuracy
that it was
uh pretty much unnecessary uh in my
opinion it was
not necessary at all to trade rooks just
yet
i wouldn't trade rooks myself what i
would do is basically
uh play might be throwing the one check
and then simply go back let's say to c2
or something
prepare f3 prepare g4 play play rook a2
maybe
if i can maybe uh play rook from
from this side with rook h2 uh you know
maybe even open g files after this this
open g5 play with
g1 rook g2 also possible or h1 h6
things like this with more rooks both
works on the board i think there is uh
you know more chances to win this
and this was i think the best technique
also engines confirm that
and uh so but you know makes perfect
sense to keep those on the board
in the game fall uh not uh
not rook c7 and keeping those wings on
the board but he played with king e2
and maybe it was sort of time travel or
something
very unstandable because it was move
number 34 so very likely move
time control was around 40. so maybe it
was time time time drop or something
um also made to remember in those days
they didn't have
uh increment so very likely when they
had
little time they had really little time
so
rook takes c6 uh rook takes c6
king d7 and right now in the game fold
f3 uh which was again uh
a mistake okay yeah this was a mistake
regulatory drugs wasn't
maybe such a big mistake but f3 is
definitely a mistake so right now
basically in this moment
alekhine had one of the two chances to
save the game
can you uh can you guys find a move
right now for black to save the game
because there's only one of the few
moments that in this game that
actually this could have happened
black to play right now and hold
and pretty much hold
a5 and after rotates b6
a5 enough after rook take rook takes b6
okay um so two suggestions uh
king c7 or a4 so let's see after uh a
first put on the board actually if a5
because this didn't happen in the game
rook b6 uh a4
after a four i would consider
that uh okay let me calculate this this
case again
before okay after this i think okay six
wins
because uh the point is that after route
is the air force straight with the rooks
and right now we cannot push because i'm
faster to queen my pawn
so i have to go king c6 and after this i
go king d3 and right now in the in the
box or like the the square and if the
king
goes to b6 i go king c3 you have to
capture this pawn
and finally go king before i'm just in
time to capture this a4 pawn that's your
point and you
cannot do anything about it at this
point and game must be winning
it is winning it's really cool and game
for for white
that's why this move uh a4 is not good
but whatever uh
takari shari sarteshni
sorry i'm butchering it but yeah king
seven is correct king c7 is correct
basically
uh right now rook a6 is not possible
because simply takes takes king b6
right so this is basically not possible
for white
and if and if rook c6 then king b7 and
this pawn suddenly there is it's very
difficult to stop to start
it's very difficult to stop spawn simply
a5 a3 just goes
and you know this extra pawn right now
for white is totally irrelevant
black has sufficient counterplay of by
pushing the a pawn
so this was and this is the game should
end so here with with a draw
but this was the only moment when um
anakin could have done that but uh you
know by some reason he played game
he was also in time travel or something
uh
mj is enough all right um
rook e8 okay uh so right now
kd3 back rook e7 so
basically uh just to sum up this moment
you have you in general in chess you
have two types of defense one's active
one is passive
and it's very fine balance to find the
you know to figure out which one is
correct
and basically uh it just comes i guess
with intuition or experience or
whatever to basically figure out in what
position
which one to apply and there is no kind
of like i
i i'm not if i'm not i'm not really
aware of
uh of like some method when to use which
because it can be
some positions the differences can be
really subtle
and it just i don't i don't know any
kind of like
guidance which when to use which it's
just kind of like comes with feeling i
guess
uh so more you study chess in general
the more feeling the more intuition you
have
so that's you know that's the main let's
say idea in my opinion how to get better
in chess just work more
and uh and yeah okay so rookie 8
happened
king d3 rookie 7
and now finally g4 basically uh right
now
uh as someone said earlier in chat uh
two weaknesses so there are two
weaknesses true
pawn a7 and d5 but they are not really
like a
two separate basis it's like they're
more like a one weakness basically
we cannot attack both you know like like
we can't attack
bone d5 we cannot like one seven but we
can't really attack one d5 in a way with
king on d7
uh you know we can't therefore we have
to create a second weakness on the other
side of the board on the king side and
that's why we need to play move g4 right
now to try to create
uh you know somewhere on the king side
uh g4
and again for follow rook e6 and right
now
uh why to what would you play here with
white white to play
questions where you try the rooks or you
do not trade rooks
mj suggested suggest rook c2
group c3 our is better okay
no trade rook c2 okay so you guys in
general don't
want to trade i can see
and i will tell you what uh if you don't
want to trade you play like ruby
string so that's generally good news
right
uh however if you want to play
like stock fish you should play rook
takes e6
which is uh you know kind of like modern
modern just pretty like
uh uh sort of refutes
it's not like really finds new solutions
to different types of problems
uh just you know chess evolves as a game
so pretty much 56 wins and after king
six g takes f5
basically uh is just winning and putting
pawn in game because after king f5 king
goes around
and basically basically have just extra
pawn essentially because we have four
versus three because these two these two
black pawns are blocked by one
and uh
pen basically uh the spawn on b5 stops
these two and
pour the four pawns on the king side
just or center
and kingside uh win win simply and
this may have been kind of like not so
clear during the game but
the analysis proves that basically this
is just winning and if g takes f5
e4 and basically uh right now if
pawns are you know trading traded
everything is just winning
again uh two pawns versus one
and if we can play move like e5 then
king goes around
and we simply uh
yeah basically we go e5 and king goes
around and the game is just over
let's say the you know king on some e7
or something we just go e5
and the king just waits and we just go
around with our king
there is no way to sorry no there's no
way to stop this king from entering
through the h file
and then at some okay maybe the king
will try to stop this
uh with like you know king g6 or
something
but okay but the point is that those
this pawn blocks these two
so uh this is not sufficient uh
you know and so essentially right now
and a5 never works a5 that works because
we take in empassau and basically
promote first that's why here after king
g6 we can play right now e6 and you know
deflect this king towards his center
capture respawn h7 and you know at some
point there will be some kind of like
outflanking or source or sort of or
whatever
say this this this is on the elementary
winning poland game
because after king h6 king h5 there is
super funk
king has to go somewhere king g5 of
course king king g6 and
simply wins again if white black was in
time to you know
uh play you know a5 or a6 this wouldn't
be
so easy but the spawn b5 blocks these
two again i'm saying
and it is simply simply winning so uh
you know the new sold new solutions to
old problems
but uh you know in what i was thinking i
was preparing this example
is maybe good that akiba didn't take or
take on e6
because it wouldn't produce such a you
know such a beautiful
end game that it did so let's go uh rook
c
uh roxy one i mean no one can fight of
stock which maybe only lc0 right
but yeah uh
roxy1 but it happened in the game so
also but
i want to give you come kind of like an
example
have general perspective on this rook c1
is also very good move
and in many positions uh
in many positions this rook you know
rook trade okay hold i'll
take that back uh here rookie six wins
because it's just forced
it just wins by force for white however
in
it could be let's say small change in a
position when it doesn't work
that's why uh okay you need to calculate
whenever you transfer the pawn
end game you need to be absolutely sure
maybe uh rubinstein
for sure could be calculated with 86 but
maybe he was not sure or maybe he
miscalculated something
and that's why he didn't play rook86 and
uh
you know in if you are not absolutely if
you are not 100 percent sure
whether route 86 wins uh or or
you know then then just don't trade
rooks because for sure with rooks on the
board you are clearly better anyway
but with others okay it's either draw or
or or you win or is a draw right so
therefore you have to
make a decision and decision making in
choice is kind of difficult sometimes
that's why rook c1
is also very good practical choice so we
shouldn't this is kind of like uh
judge reiner robinson by roxy one
because also this move is to a winning
position
just rook takis is much faster and
easier uh according to the
engines right but roxy one is
also very very good so uh rookie seven
followed
right now and right now uh rook h1 we go
from this side just as i said rook
the rogue has possibility of going to
swinging between king side and queen
side
and right now goes to the king side king
e6
uh right now back now to e1
uh swinging again now to a1 so this idea
this strategy right now by rubinstein
playing rook a1 rook e1 and rh1 and so
on
this is a very common strategy in uh
such end games
we are not showing yet where whatever we
want to do
we are not declaring our intentions and
uh you know generally it's a good
strategy because first of all we can win
some time because our opponent will have
to figure out
whatever uh you know whatever we are
playing or something we're maybe just
playing
um no plant playing anything just
playing moves but uh
you know we are slowly you know putting
some pressure here right now with the
attack pawn on a7
early attack pawn h7 so there is some
pressure on
involved you know on black so right now
king d6
back to c1 you know like slowly
maneuvering this kind of like strategy
is
you know uh popular in modern chess
i myself employed many games like that
and uh
you know it was pioneered by you know
such
players like rubinstein so king d7
and c6 final girl got
activating the rook f8 and
yeah in this position how would you
continue here with white how would you
continue here with white
mj yeah correct correct basically uh
king has to go around king has done his
job on d3 and now it's time for the king
to get
to the game for this square
so this is the plan and totally correct
okay good job
and this is exactly what rubinstein did
so such long maneuvers
uh you know are not uh
you know common and especially very
common like involves days
and rubinstein was as i say pioneer
again the rule do not hurry there is no
need to rush anything
there is no need to rush anything the
rule do not hurry applies
and phrase i see suggestion of uh
gtx f5 and the e4
and uh first of all after it takes f5
i play root x5 so basically you are
trading the pawns
you're allowing your black group to
activate
let's say if activate my rook who knows
what's going to happen
you're not going to go you get e4
because i think with the opponent
opponent upon here
you are not getting anything with this
which takes a five
and why because gtx 5 is premature it's
simply premature you cannot
rush a decision like this by taking this
pawn on f5
you know it's simply premature that's
why
kingitu has been played very good a very
good move by rubinstein
uh rook f7 the the thing is let's
let's see what happens to look see it if
we look if the rooks are swapped
and right now white wins in the same way
just as we discussed earlier because of
gtx f6565 and e4
again this with this wins because uh if
pawns are traded you know kinky freaking
e4 right
uh simply you know we have winning
position and if
white black doesn't play we go uh of our
pawn to f e5 and go
this way just as we discussed earlier
same same same end game
so rook city doesn't work that's why uh
rook f7 alham waits
king f2 king g3 gradually improving our
position right now
we want we're very close to going this
way rookie 8 attacking spawn e3
now rook c3 rook comes back we
uh we want to we want to defense pawn
with the rook and
go king h4k in g5 so uh rook e7 followed
and now uh king h4 so
right now if we can't get our king to g5
the game will be just over
you know you'll just fall on the five
okay g takes the five g65 king g5
05 is a huge weakness basically we got
to create second wicket on the king side
right now
and that's that is the main objective
here for white uh
to create second windows on the king
side so after king h4
g takes the 5g takes the 5 as a fret so
black plays with h6
to stop you know king king g5
but right now pawn on h6 is also
becoming a weakness
so right now i mean yeah
it's not as safe as it was on h7 because
point h7 supports this pawn structure
right
this pawn structure is the same more
solid rather than this
uh you know king h4 h6 this pawn
structure
pawn jesus could be vulnerable but for
now we cannot get to this pawn
right because pawn only three is hanging
so it makes sense to play with king g3
for viking f2 back and then rook c6
maybe at some point
or uh maybe we bring the king back to f2
and then somehow go a c1 rook h pawn
because pawn h7 is also not guarded
as well as was here one example one of
some of the example lines that i'm
thinking about right now
say rook e8 let's say uh let's say take
taking f2
just for example and you say ruby seven
of course there was okay three on the
way but just for example i want to just
show example line
let's say roo goes here uh attack
respond let's say king d6 already
released to rook c6
right if through king d8 we can go right
now this way attack this point from here
if this rook goes here we are winning
with h5 because this pawn is the
weakness as well
so only move is to play move rook e6
and again we can just wait it out we can
bring this king here first
and then we can see where go rook h5 or
k1 because we can also
remember that rook a1 attacks pawn on a7
it's not easy to defend it too
black has to have always raided this
movie because let's say rookie sound
already loses to gay one
and the white wins right so this is
very very very uh difficult position
already
so in this position after king g3
alexander
h5 and
right now i think that
somewhat inaccurate move uh because
they play with king h4 and king h4
is gives black some hope to save this by
after takes takes take stakes
and this in this position you know the
cure can get activated
uh through each file and similar there
was something similar in the game so
we'll discuss it in a second
uh something similar very similar
happened
in the game so uh
i don't want to discuss this particular
position but uh
you know instead of king h4 we was i
wanted to
say what was the most was the most uh
you know the simplest way to win
simply takes takes king h4 basically
again just create this weakness on f5
attack on h5 the game is just decided
let's say if rook j and
g7 if rook h7 we can just
very likely capture pawn five because if
h4
can get five h3 can you just go to see
what we are in time to stop this
and then we are winning
uh also we can start with like rook g1
or something also as possible
but yeah simply taking on five
sufficient and
also we can start with move like rook g6
or something king jesus i mean
anything wins and if we're g7 trying to
activate this rook from g1 trying to
maybe go for rook b1
we need to remember that uh there are
also ideas of attacking spawn with rook
a3
but the first king h6 let's say ah
g2 because if this rook goes here not
only we have rook a3 but also we have
king g6
right so if let's say rook starts trying
to keep this king cut here
we can go for rook a3 and attack this
pawn and we are simply simply winning
so uh in the game of king h4 right now
uh hd
g4 dk was getting some chance in the
game for however h7
and right now again king g5 was a
mistake uh in the game
uh which up in the game this was
supposed to be played and again king g5
some just like just as we discussed
right the same position
lean to the same position white wins
however king g5 was played
and here right now alejan had a chance
right now al-qaeda is present in great
defense so this is what i wanted to
uh mention here
alekhan understood that uh he cannot
just wait
he could he had a great feeling for
dynamics and he understood that in such
endgame
where he's been you know slowly but
surely you know
uh outplayed he cannot just wait and
wait for
him just wait here and uh not do
anything because then
white strategy will be simply sufficient
so he has to [ __ ] out of some conduct
and he did that by playing takes stakes
taking everything here g4
and right now rook h1 and the idea is to
play after king g5 to play with group b1
and honestly according to my analysis i
think that
[Music]
i think that this position should be
drawn
with correct defense however uh you know
this
that's why this move king g5 was a big
mistake you should have taken on g5
earlier uh like in this position to take
the fight was winning uh
in this position uh okay even best make
mistakes
but nonetheless there was a lot of
there's lots to learn from was mistake
because this gave
the opportunity to save the game with b1
and right now after uh rook a3
uh okay king g6 also is possible but
then rook takes b5 is extremely sharp
who knows which part which ones are
faster these two or maybe f1
i'm not sure and according to autonomous
uh probably they're equally fast so this
should be drawn
and um generation solids is there is
hallucination um okay rougey free so
that's why uh
bishop and free and right now this is
the final puzzle of the
of this evening how black can save the
game right now
play better than alekhein
thank you i hope you like i hope you'll
like it
ask king yes correct king e6
correct king is activity activity
activity activity
uh we need to activate the king
because with our active king we can
only active king only of active pieces
we can save this uh that's why
uh rook g1 for it was a huge mistake
because right now ago king of six this
king is sort of stuck there
and the rook takes p5 is also not
sufficient because after rook takes a 7
you know this let's say king e6 now we
take and this rook is also positive we
just play f5 next
and that's why the point is after king
e6 to after
gay seven meet this group is g1 check
and hit this king and then go king f5
if let's say if possible or
african-american it will go
e1 attack is probably free that's why
king e6
was the best move which was missed by
alekhine he played rook takes b5 and the
re7 the game is just simply over because
king 16 g6
the rest is pretty much simple uh just
pawn goes forward there is no way of
stopping it
again this king is cut right now on a
seventh rank important idea
uh of in end games you know carrying the
king on the you know
some rank and right now this king
black king is cut on the seventh rank
right now and counts get to eight ranked
start this pawn and simply is going
forward by itself
king h7 look at three just f7
king comes to f8 okay they repeat it
like few times
and finally king gets to f8
and finally after rook d1
and you know there's just no way of
stopping this pawn the king comes to e8
rookie one king d8
rook f1 just check
now king back for the building that was
sort of bridge with rookie 7 check
i mean after we want to be seven we said
we wanna try to be seven
rupee seven anyway and now very nice
move rookies and this is the final move
the game and i really like it i just
really want to show this
till the end because this rook seven is
just a class it's just
really classy move not allowing any
the smallest counter play like the even
like the shade of contour play nothing
rook c7 cuts king right now again on the
c5 right now
and the pawn promotes the queen
alejand resigned there is nothing he can
do he just resigned
and yeah the game is over
so yeah that's uh one of
few of the end games of akiba mission
i wanted to share with you guys today uh
there were
there are lots of more of course there
are lots of more i had more prepared but
you know it's just time is limited so i
showed
the most let's say famous games or like
against let's say lasker
right and um neem savage i know
i didn't show maybe another day i will
show you know against alejand this one
and
uh against janovsky maybe some of them
some also more i think you've shown but
anyway i had more prepared but
you know i think there's already plenty
of material
and uh i think there's lots of
to learn from those games and even
though as i say you know rubbish i made
made mistakes
uh you know modern engines show it right
but it doesn't really matter for let's
say qualitative let's say or like you
know
for learning purpose even if he can just
improve on
his strategy or like his play you can
only learn from this
so uh but anyway um you know the way he
was playing
the ideas that he was inventing let's
say you know idea of king
he took him f2k freaking age 14 g5 it's
a very long
plan and uh of course you know you guys
come up with this quickly
uh which is great but at the time it was
completely
you know new completely new right it was
so many games there and game theory
wasn't that developed and
such ideas are just classic and it's
very good to know such end games
all right so thank you guys for today
and i will see you i hope you guys
enjoyed it so
um yeah thank you and take care and see
you next time